des gestes fluides pour certains ralenti
pour d'autres dans les étroites lignes
d'eau de la piscine de belle-ile les
nageurs commence à peiner déjà 20 heures
qu'il se relaient toutes les 30 minutes
pour relever le défi du bol d'eau 2015
vingt-quatre heures de nage on continue
mais aujourd'hui les derniers rôles et
son douloureux sur cette demi heure là
j'ai fait 1700 m 1700 mètres ça fait du
3 km 4 à l'heure à peu près un bon
rythme mais faut le tenir quoi c'est ça
il faut pas partir trop vite parce
qu'après on évite grille et d'ailleurs
je les ai vus à ae car j'étais déjà bien
fatigué et le dernier quart d'heure je
pense que j'ai beaucoup cochet puisque
nager au bord du bassin ou dans l'eau
certains attendent leur tour avec un peu
d'appréhension
j'ai nagé soutenu
il atteint et ça c'est pas très bien
passé j'étais un petit peu déstabilisés
par le bas ça que je ne connais pas à la
table de marque
c'est aussi le marathon des petites
croix chaque aller-retour des nageurs et
notés car en plus de l'endurance c'est
la distance qui récompensait à la fin
pas question donc de s'endormir entre
deux longueurs lydia à la recette pour
tenir un beau stylo de la patience et
puis de l'encouragement pour les nageurs
et un bon café
c'est çà et là besoin pour tenir le coup
et bien et pour ceux qui ne tiennent pas
le coup il vient une solution se laisser
porter par le sommeil pendant que les
autres nageurs assure car le bol d'eau
c'est surtout un travail d' équipe
conviviale mais éprouvant on part
toujours en disant je vais pas me faire
mal je plonge je me fais pas mal parce
que j'ai plusieurs demi heure à faire
finalement quand on est dans l'eau on se
dira ça serait bien quand même que
j'essaie de faire le plus de distance
possible
donc en fait l'envi vient en mangeant
quoi et a finalement à la fin on a
toujours un petit peu mal nés dans les
années 80 le bol d'eau a longtemps
attiré des nageurs de clubs de la région
aujourd'hui il s'ouvre au grand public
amateur de longueur